[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم بعد اربع سنوات من اغلاق السفاره
الاسرائيليه في القاهره اقيمت مراسم اعاده
افتتاح السفاره باشراف وكيل وزاره
الخارجيه الاسرائيليه دوري جولد الذي قال
ان اسرائيل ومصر بقياده نتنياهو والسيسي
تتعاونان من اجل جلب الاستقرار والازدهار
الى المنطقه نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لكي
نناقشه في محورين ما دلاله اعاده افتتاح
السفاره الاسرائيليه في القاهره بالتزامن
مع الذكرى الرابعه
لاغلاقها وما هي حيثيات وانعكاسات اعاده
توطيد العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين مصر
[موسيقى]
واسرائيل
بعد اربع سنوات على اقتحام عشرات
المتظاهرين مقر السفاره الاسرائيليه في
القاهره للمطالبه بقطع العلاقات بين مصر
واسرائيل في فتره ما بعد ثوره يناير اعيد
افتتاح السفاره الاسرائيليه لدى مصر
ايذانا بتوطيد العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين
القاهره وتل ابيب تحرك دبلوماسي سبقه قرار
السلطات المصريه في يونيو الماضي اعاده
السفير المصري لدى اسرائيل بعد ثلاث سنوات
على قرار الرئيس السابق محمد مرسي بسحب
السفير المصري احتجاجا على الحرب
الاسرائيليه على غزه قرار افتتاح السفاره
الاسرائيليه في القاهره اثار انتقادات من
قبل المعارضين فيما قال موالون للنظام
المصري انه امر طبيعي ومشروع المزيد من
التفاصيل في تقرير ناصر ايه
طاهر من ميدان التحرير جاؤوا كانوا يعرفون
ما يريدون ما لا يريدون وفي غمره ثورتهم
على النظام قال المصريون لا لاستمرار
علاقات بلادهم مع اسرائيل قالوها في جمعه
تصحيح المسار في التاسع من سبتمبر عام
مذاك اغلقت السفاره مرت اربعه اعوام
وتبدلت
مصر شاء الاسرائيليون ان يكون يوم اعاده
افتتاح سفارتهم في عهد عبد الفتاح السيسي
موافقا يوم اغلاقها لعلها رساله وفي رساله
اخرى لا تقل استفزازا اقيم حفل افتتاح
رسمي لمقر سكن السفير الاسرائيلي ليكون
مقرا مؤقتا للسفاره من تل ابيب حضر وفد
على راسه المدير العام لوزاره الخارجيه
دوري جولد والسفير المعتمد لدى مصر حيم
كورين وطاقم السفاره وشارك في الحفل كبار
الموظفين في وزاره الخارجيه المصريه كما
حضر السفير الامريكي في القاهره
اجواء تشبه الاعياد اشعرت الاسرائيليين
بانه رد اليهم الاعتبار لا غرابه ان اعاده
فتح السفاره الاسرائيليه اثارت جدلا
سياسيا وشعبيا في مصر وخلفت حاله من
الاستياء كبيره مع ذلك يذهب موالون
للسلطات المصريه في دفاعهم عن القرار الى
القول انه امر طبيعي ومشروع بل متوقع وانه
قرار اسرائيلي لا دخل للقاهره فيه لكن
القاهره هي من عينت سفيرا جديدا لها في تل
ابيب في يونيو الماضي بعد ثلاثه اعوام من
سحبها سفيرها هناك في عهد الرئيس مرسي على
خلفيه الحرب الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه
فريق اخر من داعم النظام المصري لا يرى في
عوده السفاره الاسرائيليه مدلولا سياسيا
وان كانت بزعمه دليلا على الاستقرار
الامني في مصر تبرير ما لا يبرر يقول
معارضون فهؤلاء يتحدثون صراحه عن ثوره
مضاده اعادت فتح السفاره ولا تخطئ اعينهم
عمق علاقه اسرائيل بنظام السيسي بل انها
في افضل حالاتها باعتراف الجانبين يباهي
ان بها بطريقه علنيه فجا يفعلان في الوقت
الذي تعزل فيه السلطه المصريه الفلسطينيين
وتشدد اجراءات حصارهم لا شك ان في مصر من
لا يرضيه ذلك غير ان التعبير عن الحنق
والاستياء بات مقتصرا على نفر من الساسه
المعارضين
خفتت اصوات المثقفين والفعاليات الشعبيه
ومعادي التطبيع كانما لا تريد تلك الاصوات
ان تعكر فرحه مصر السيسي او كانما تدرك ان
اسرائيل هي اكثر الطرق اختصارا الى رضا
المجتمع الدولي
واعترافه موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيفين
عبر سكايب من فريبور في سويسرا حاتم عزام
نائب رئيس حزب الوسط ومن واشنطن مع توفيق
حمي كبير الباحثين في معهد الدراسات
السياسيه سيد حميد ما دلاله اعاده فتح
السفاره الان
برايك انا اعتقد دلاله هذا ان النظام
المصري يريد ان يعلن لمجتمع العالمي انه
يحترم معاهدات وبالنسبه لاحترام المعاهدات
هو شيء هو الافضل سياسيا واخلاقيا و
ودينيا وقانونيا هو احترام المعاهدات ولا
ننسى ابدا ان معاهده السلام المصريه كان
نتاجها ان عادت سينا الينا وقناه السويس
والسياحه في سينا فهؤلاء ال يريدون
السفاره بمعنى انهم لا يريدون تطبيعا مع
اسرائيل وكانهم يقولون فلتعود سيناء الى
اسرائيل ولتقف قناه السويف سويس وتقف
السياحه فاعتقد ان ان الاداره المصريه هنا
تعلن انها اداره واقعيه برجماتيه تتحرك
لمصلحه الدوله وهذا هو المطلوب يعني هو
احترام معاهدات دوليه لكن في مجال حقوق
الانسان الدوله المصريه مفترض عضو بالامم
المتحده بالجمعيه العامه لديها ايضا
ارتباطات بمعاهدات دوليه تختص بحقوق
الانسان ورغم ذلك اصدرت مئات احكام
الاعدام مثلا لماذا عند اسرائيل تحترم
المعاهدات عند حقوق الانسان لا تحترم
المعاهدات
والله اي دوله الاولويه ليها الابتي او
عمليه استقرار الدوله فما يتطلبه لحظات في
استقرار الدوله يعني ب بعد احداث سبتمبر
كما ذكرت سابقا في اكثر من مره اضطرت
الولايات المتحده ان تاخذ بعض قوانين
الاستثنائيه فكل دوله بتتحرك لابد ان
تتحرك بمصالحها واين هي مصالحها يعني
معذره دعني اقول لك
شي تسميهم الارهابيين المصر الان النظام
الحالي يتخذ تدابير ضد كل من هو
معارض يعني المقارنه هنا لا ادري ان كانت
تصلح لان للاسف الكثير من المعارضين
تسببوا في تحفيز التيار المتطرف بصوره او
باخرى ويساعد باضعاف الدوله فالدوله تحتاج
حاليا ان تكون قويا كي تقاوم هذا
التطرف سيزداد التطرف وتزداد الامور سوء
في مص الظلم ايضا يزيد التطرف هذا يعني
قاعده منطقيه معروفه الظلم يولد التطرف
عاده سيد توفيق على حال هذا ليس موضوعنا
فقط عرجنا عليه سيد حاتم عزام هل لديك راي
اخر في هذا الموضوع لماذا اعيد افتتاح
السفاره وبهذا التوقيت نفس التاريخ الزمن
الذي كان اعترض الشعب على وجود هذه
السفاره على ارضي تحياتي لحضرتك ولضيفك
وساده المشاهدين دعيني الاول يعني اتوجه
بالنعي لاسره الدكتور مجاهد حسن طبيب مصري
صاحب يعني عنده 37 سنه من محافظه بني سويف
تم تصفيه اليوم من قوات الداخليه التابعه
لسلطه عبد الفتاح السيسي بخمس رصاصات في
البطن والصدر طبيب شاب مشكلته ان هو ينتمي
الى حزب الحريه والعداله وهو شخص سلمي لم
يمارس عنف وبالتالي هذا مؤشر شديد الخطوره
انه مسلسل التصفيه الجسديه للمعارضين
السياسيين يمشي في مصر على قدم وساق وهو
نفسه بالمناسبه نفس الممارسات التي
تمارسها الجماعات المتطرفه مثل داعش ا
عوده الى الموضوع اللي حضرتك بتطرح
الحقيقه اذا حطي
يعني افتتاح خبر افتتاح سفاره اسرائيل
اليوم في القاهره على خط هنلاقيه مستقيم
مع كل سياسات سلطه عبد الفتاح السيسي منذ
انقلاب الثالث من يونيو بمعنى انه هذا
الانقلاب بدايه ويعني لا يعني يعني يعني
لا يتسع المجال للتدليل ولكن هذا التدليل
تم بوضوح من قبل انه مدعوم اسرائيليا
ومدعوم دوليا نمره اثنين انه تم احتفاء
بسلطه عبد الفتاح السيسي منذ اليوم الاول
بعد الانقلاب وتم تسه تسميته بطل قومي في
الصحافه الاسرائيليه نمره ثلاثه وده الاهم
عبد الفتاح السيسي يسدد فواتير الى القوى
العظمى التي تدعم سلطه الكيان الاسرائيلي
المغتصب بالارض الفلسطينيه عن طريق تقديم
التنازلات التنازلات في سيناء وتنازلات في
تطبيع العلاقات اكثر وبالمناسبه وانا اريد
ان اعقب على المتحدث الضيف الذي قال انه
احترام المعاهدات واجب ديني وانا بحب ان
هو الحقيقه يعني بيستخدم الدين الان في
تبرير هذه السياسه والدين من هذا براء
لانه الهجمه الشرسه التي تتم على مقدسات
المسلمين الان ونحن نتحدث في المسجد
الاقصى التي دعت يعني البطريرك الكنيسه
الارثوذكسيه في فلسطين انه يقول انه نحن
نواجه خطر شديد على المسجد الاقصى ويجب
حمايته حتى يعني بموجب ال يعني الوعد
العمري فهذا هذا ينافي نحن امام نحن امام
سلطه تطبع بشكل كامل بل تتعاون مع الكيان
الاسرائيلي بشكل امني والطائرات بدون طيار
وتقصف اهالي في سيناء وهذا معروف وتم نقله
عبر اهالي المصريين في سيناء
وبالتالي هناك حاله تزاوج بين سلطه عبد
الفتاح السيسي ونتنياهو وانا عايز اسال
سؤال اذا كان نتنياهو وال حيين كوين ولا
كوهين هو من سيجلب الاستقرار لمصر
بالتعاون مع السيسي هل عصام سلطان ومحمد
البلتاجي واحمد ماهر وعلاء عبد الفتاح
اللي مسجونين هم الخطر على استقرار هل
اسراء عبد الفتاح وحسام خالف وسناء سيف
وهاني الجمل وغيرهم من المعتقلين المصريين
في السجون الان هم الخطر هذا موضوع اخر
سييد حاتم بالنسبه لاسرائيل الرجل يقول
هنالك احترام لمعاهده بين البلدين شئنا ام
ابينا تمتد لعش وقعت منذ منذ عشرات
السنوات حتى مرسي نفسه قيل انه بعث برساله
لبيريز لماذا الان يعاب على السيسي ان
يعيد افتاح السفاره هو اجراء طبيعي مكمل
لمعاهده سلام بين مصر واسرائيل لا دعيني
اختلف مع حضرتك او مع وجهه النظر المطروحه
دي اولا معاهده السلام التي ورثتها ورثها
الشعب المصري عن حقوه تاريخيه معينه لا
تحتم بالضروره اي موقف سياسي يتخذ
يعني كسحب السفير او اغلاق السفار هذا
موقف سياسي لا يعني الغاء معاهده السلام
على الاطلاق وهذا التزاوج تزاوج بين
الاثنين او محاوله الدمج بينهم شيء باطل
وبالتالي حينما يكون الان سلطه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي تمارس هذه العنصريه ضد اخواننا
في فلسطين وضد المقدسات المسلمين فاعتقد
والعالم كله بالمناسبه حضرتك بتلاحظي انه
هناك انتفاضه عالميه بتقاطع في في حمله
مقاطعه عالميه ضد الكيان الاسرائيلي
المغتصب الارض الفلسطينيه هذه الحمله
العالميه يعني مش عربيه ولا اسلاميه فقط
وينضم اليها كثير من الاحرار في العالم ف
دي نمره واحد نمره اثنين هذه هجمه شرسه
الان في التوقيت نمره ثلاثه الحرب على غزه
وما حدث فيها من جرائم ضد الانسانيه فكل
هذه الظروف تعطي كثير من المبررات بل
الكثير من الاسباب التي تجعل مصر لا تفتح
هذه السفاره بل تسحب السفير وهذا عمل
دبلوماسي سياسي مشروع طيب انقل هذا الى
سيد توفيق حميد سيد توفيق حميد اذا سحب
السفير وعدم اعاده افتاح سفاره لا يؤثر
على المعاهده معاهده السلام وعلى ارتباط
على ارتباط مصر بمعاهده امام المجتمع
الدولي وامام العالم وامام التزاماتها لا
علاقه لهذا بذاك لا يؤثر هذا على ذاك اذا
اي لما يعني لما دخول في هذا الباب الذي
سيجلب الانتقادات في ظل ما تتعرض ض له
فلسطين والشعب الفلسطيني من اعتداءات
اسرائيليه وتهويد للقدس وتعرض الاقصى
للخطر في ظل كل ذلك وفي ظل الجرائم نفسها
التي مرث ضد
غزه سيدتي الفضيله هناك لي بعض الحقائق
هنا ف معاهده السلام ليست مجرد ورقه ولكن
ينبغي ان يحترم الناس ما تعهدوا به ومنها
وجود علاقات طبيعيه بين البلادين وبين
علاقات طبيعيه تعني وجود سفاره فلا داعي
للف والدوران في هذا الامر فمده السلام
تعني علاقه طبيعيه تعني وجود السفاره
السيد الفاضل الضيف بيحاول يصور هنالك انت
انت تدرك ان ان شعبيا شعبيا هناك تحفظات
كثيره وكان دائما حتى التعامل المصري
الحكومي ايام مبارك كان على استحياء في
الموضوع الان يقال ان العلاقات بين مصر
واسرائيل لم تتوطد مثل ايام السيسي
بزمانها كله
شوفي حضرتك اولا نمره واحد لو هنحكم
الامور بالصوره الشعبيه فلابد ان نقر شيء
بوضوح ان ما حدث في السفاره الاسرائيليه
من هجوم من اربع سنين بالصوره اللي شفناها
ده ده شيء غير اخلاقي شيء همجي شيء مخالف
لكل الاعراف وغير مقبول بالمره يعني عشان
بس ايه ما نحاول نبرر شيء ما تبقيش انت
مديه معاهده لحد يجي عندك ارضك او بيتك
وبعد كده تعتدي عليه ونحاول ان نبرر ذلك
فدعنا نبقى صريحين في هذا اما الامر
الثاني فالضيف الفاضل بيحاول يصور ان وجود
علاقه مع اليهود هي علاقه هتكون سلبيه على
مصر اليهود كانوا موجودين في مصر سيدتي
ايام الملك فاروق وكانت مصر في اوج عظمتها
ولما تركها اليهود اصبحت الان في مشاكل
كثيره يعني على عكس ما يقول الكثيرين او
الكثيرون فاننا
لصوره واقعيه
لوجدنا ان لو كان اليهود هما سبب المشاكل
لو كان اليهود هما سبب المشاكل في الدول
واليات الاقتصاديه وما لا تحرف النقاش ولا
تاخذه حيث لم يكن اصلا المقصود لم يتحدث
احد عن يهود تحدثنا عن اسرائيل
مح اسمح لي لو سمحت لم يتحدث احد عن يهود
لم يتحدث احد عن يهود تحدثنا عن اسرائيل
محتل اسرائيلي محتل عن يهودي لم ياتي فقط
مصر ا بول اوروبا ومن امريكا وطرد
الفلسطيني الاصلي وطرد الفلسطيني وجلس
مكانه عن هذا نتحدث لا تقل لي اشياء يعني
تخصص بالدين اليهودي سيدتي حينما تجدي في
في طب اعطيني فرصه اتكلم حينما تجدي في
شارتر او ميثاق حماس البند السابع بيتكلم
عن اباده اليهود وهذا ما يعلنه في الجوامع
والمساجد وخطاباتهم كلها تتكلم عن اباده
كل اليهود وسابي نساهم اذا لا تطالبي غيرك
ان يعطيك ارضا السادات حصل على كل ما اراد
باظهار السلام فل تظهر حماس
سلامت عن السابع الذي يقضي باباده كل
يهودي انذاك ستحل القضيه سيدتي يا سيد
توفيق انت تنتقي هنا تمارس سياسه الانتقاء
بند من حماس بند من غير حماس هذا هذا ليس
الموضوع هنالك عشرات البنود التي اذكرها
لك من حاخامات تقول ان العرب حشرات وينبغي
سحقهم هذا ليس موضوعنا الان سيد توفيق ن
سيد توفيق عزان ليس في
دستور انا هنا لا دستور اسرائيل يقول يريد
ان ان يقول ان الدوله الاسرائيليه دوله
يهوديه يعني هل تريد عنصريه اكثر من ذلك
وطائف سيد حاتم عزام لديك تعليق نعم انا
اولا اشكرك ان حضرتك رددت بالنيابه عني
وخليني ااكد انه انا لم اتحدث بطائف ولم
اتحدث على اساس ديني انا تحدثت على اساس
مبادئي واساس حقوقي واساس انساني انا لم
اذكر كلمه يهود انا قلت السلطه
الصهيونيه المحتله والسلطه الاسرائيليه
المحتله ا دي نمره واحده فشكرا ان حضرتك
يعني بدرتي بالرد على هذه المغالطه الذي
يحاول المحاور ان يقعن فيها وانا لم
اقولها نمره اثنين انا قلت لحضرتك انه
بطريرك الروم الارثوذكس حتى حينما استشهدت
لحضرتك استشهدت بطاركه الروم الارثوذكس في
القدس بتقول الحكومه الاسرائيليه المحتله
بتنفذ مخطط تهويد المسجد الاقصى وضيف
حضرتك بيتكلم على الدين واحترام المعاهدات
فانا عايز اقول انه ما يحدث الان من سلطه
عبد الفتاح السيسي هو استكمال هذا
التزاوج وتقديم الفواتير لاسرائيل ومن
يدعمها دوليا على ممارستها نمره اثنين انا
عايز ااكد لحضرتك انه هناك مساحه من
الدبلوماسيه السياسيه التي يستطيع فيها اي
انسان ان يمارس عمل سياسي ان يسحب سفير
وان يغلق سفاره احتجاجا على سياسات عنصريه
واحتجاجا على سياسات استيطان واحتجاجا على
نيه باتت مبيته وواضحه انه هناك قتل ممنهج
واغتصاب لمقدسات الشعب الفلسطيني والعرب
والمسلمين النقطه الاخيره اللي عايز
اقولها لحضرتك ا انا لست مستغربا وكما قلت
لحضرتك يعني قرار افتتاح السفاره متماشي
تماما مع شيطنه المقاومه الفلسطينيه سواء
كانت حماس او غير حماس
ا وخنقها في غزه و
في نفس الوقت الاحتفاء بالعدو الاسرائيلي
والصهيوني على انه هو الشريك الذي سيجلب
باستقرار مع انه الناظر بكل بكل المعايير
سواء كانت معايير عربيه او اسلاميه او حتى
معايير برجماتيه يرى ان حدود مصر الشرقيه
هي بوابه لحفظ الامن القومي المصري وان
التطبيع مع الكيان الصهيوني غير اخلاقي
وغير انساني وايضا خطر على الامن القومي
المصري ا ولكن يعني سؤال قصير جدا جدا
يقول البعض ان هذه العلاقه مع اسرائيل
ليست جديده اولا وثانيا هي تنم عن ذكاء
سياسي الان لتسكين الجبهه معها يعني مصر
لا تحتاج الان الى عداوه في ظل ظروفها
الحاليه وبالتالي هذا ذكاء سياسي من قبل
السيسي هو الحقيقه خليني اقول لك هو
انتهازيه يعني انا لا اسميه ذكاء بل اسميه
انتهازيه سلطه عبد الفتاح السيسي ان كانت
ناجحه في شيء فهي ناجحه غير القتل والدم
فهي ناجحه في فكره الانتها يه السياسيه هو
يتحالف مع بشار الاسد الان وكان من قبل
متحالف مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ويتحالف مع ايران الان ويتحالف مع روسيا
وكان يذهب الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
يقول لهم بس انتم ادونا الاباتشي وبالتالي
عبد الفتاح السيسي لا يعرف سوى الرز يعني
او يعني الاموال ولا يعرف سوى كل ما يدعم
سلطته العسكريه الفاشيه وبالتالي تقديم
فروض الولاء والطاعه ل الكيان الصهيوني
وسلطه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي هي من ضمن
الفواتير التي تسدد لان هذا النظام مفتقد
الى شعبيه
وشرعيه داخليه وبالتالي هو يبحث عنها
خارجيه اعود اليك فاصل قصير اذا نواصل
بعده هذه
[موسيقى]
الحلقه اهلا بكم من جديد مباشره الى توفيق
حميد من واشنطن ما وجاهه الطرح الذي يقول
ان العلاقه علاقه نظام السيسي مع اسرائيل
وان توطيدها هي يعني تقريبا بوابته
الدوليه للحصول على اعتراف
دولي شوفي سيدتي لا نستطيع ان نلوم الرئيس
السيسي على محاولته ان يصلح حال مصر باي
صوره من الصور بمعنى ان مسؤوليه اي رئيس
في العالم هي مصلحه شعبه ودولته دي
المسؤوليه الاولى الرئيسيه له فلا يستطيع
احد يعني ضيفنا الفاضل يعاتب الرئيس
السيسي ان هو بيعمل اشياء في مصلحه مصر
يعني هو ماذا يقترح يقترح على سبيل المثال
دخول مصر في عداءات دوليه تنتهي بمشاكل
لنا لا حص لا قدره لنا بتحملها يعني كونك
تهتمي بمصلحه دولتك ده شيء لا في عيب
الاطلاق واحب ان اوجه اسئله قصيره جدا
يعني سؤالين كده سراع للضيف الفاضل اولا
يا ريت يقول لي ما ما موقفه مما كانوا
يعلمون ونحن صغار ايام عبد ال ناصر في
المدارس ان الفلسطينيين باعوا ارضهم
لليهود يا ريت ده كان في كتب التاريخ في
وقت عبد الناصر الامر الثاني السؤال
الثاني هو لماذا لا ارا يتكلم بهذا الحماس
عن اليهود اللي طردوا ايضا من مصر واخذت
ممتلكاتهم وكثير منهم وكله يعلم هذا حين
هؤلاء الذين عاشوا في تلك الفتره من ايام
عبد الناصر راوا ما حدث فما موقفه منهم
هؤلاء مصريين لماذا لا اراه يتكلم بنفس
الحماس وهنالك يهود في المغرب مازالوا
هناك هنالك يهود في اليمن مازالوا في
اماكنهم اليهودي الذي ترك يا سيد توفي
جيتيت تبقى في العالم كله دراسات اقدمها
لك موجوده على الانترنت لو بحثت عنها
الصهاينه والمتمم الكبار هم من جذبوا
هؤلاء اليهود الى اسرائيل يقدمون له لهم
فرص عمل تعليم مجاني بيوت منازل يستوطنون
منازل الفلسطين يطردون العصابات الصهيونيه
طردت الفلسطينيين وجلبت هؤلاء باغرائه بال
وبعروض يعني حتى لا نشوه التاريخ هنا لكن
سؤالي لك هو سؤالي لك سؤالي لك هذا ليس
موضوعنا ارجوك سؤال لك انه انت تقول ان
الدوله او النظام السياسي من حقه ان يحفظ
مصالحه ومصالح الدوله لكن كيف يحفظ مصالح
مصر في المبادره بهو ان يخطب ود اسرائيل
عبر المبادره باعاده السفير والمبادره
باعاده افتتاح السفاره في حين ان اسرائيل
لم تكن تتوسله لذلك لماذا المبادره يعني
ما ما الذي كان سيحصل لو لم يفعل ذلك كانت
مصر
ستنهار والله ان فرع فرح اسرائيل الحالي
بعوده السفاره يؤكد انها كانت رغبه
اسرائيليه ايضا ليست فقط مبادره ولكن ليس
من المنطق ان يكون معك علاقه طبيعيه مع
دوله تبعا لاتفاق السلام وثم تتركيها اربع
سنوات بدون سفاره يعني ما هو
شيء غير منطقي يعني اعتقد دا ترحاب بعوده
العلاقات وبر ان ان ان السكيورتي في مصر
او الحاله الامنيه في مصر بدات تتحسن يعني
الاسرائيليين مش هيحطوا السفاره لو ظل لو
الحاله الامنيه كانت ملتهبه فده بيض طمانه
للعالم اجمع وهنا في امريكا ان الحاله
الامنيه بدات تتحسن لدرجه ان اسرائيل
قادره تفتح سفارتها فاعتقد ان هو ان هو
مثل هام جدا لتطوير الاقتصاد المصري وانا
لا ارى عيبا ان يهتم الرئيس السيسي بتطوير
مصر اذا كان الامر يحتاج الى علاقه طيبه
مع اسرائيل فلتكن طيب اختم مع السيد حاتم
عزام على عجاله يعني بالنسبه للاسئله
طرحها يعني تقريبا انا ردت عليه هذا ليس
موضوعنا انا اريد منك تعليق اخير على
مساله ان ال ما قاله ردا على سؤال ان
مصلحه الدوله المصريه ان تفعل ما
فعلته نعم مصلحه الدو اولا انا لا اعاتب
السيسي ولا اعاتب ما يسميه الضيف الكريم
الرئيس السيسي لان انا لا اعتبره الرئيس
منتخب ا ولكن انتخب رئيس في مصر وتم
الانقلاب عليه نمره اثنين انا بعتبر انه
عبد الفتاح السيسي مجرم ضد الانسانيه قتل
الاف المصريين يعتقل عشرات الالاف
وبالتالي انا لا اعاتبه يعني هو فعل كثيرا
من الجرم ولكن انا تحدث فيما يخص مصر
اجابه على سؤال حضرتك اجابه على سؤال
حضرتك الحقيقه لا يعني عوده السفاره
الاسرائيليه لا تاتي على الاولويات على
الاطلاق من ضمن فكره اعاده الاستق ليست
اولويه اذا بهذه الفكره اختم شكرا جزيلا
لك عبر سكايب من سويسرا حاتم عزام نائب
رئيس حزب الوسط ومن واشنطن اشكر توفيق
حميد كبير الباحثين في معهد بوتوماك
للدراسات السياسيه واشكر متابعتكم بهذا
تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر
نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه جديده فيما وراء
خبر جديد فالى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ا